[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue le gouvernement at il
eu cette fois ci la main ferme le
ministre de l'intérieur le premier
ministre ont annoncé une série de
mesures visant à mieux protéger les
policiers à sanctionner plus durement
ceux qui s'en prennent aux forces de
l'ordre
on en débat on en débat avec vous ce
soir on en débat avec alexis brézet
bonsoir ex directeur des rédactions du
figaro est avec nous ce soir à béatrice
giblin bonsoir berre sas rédactrice
directrice de la revue de géopolitique
hérodote en france le géographique ce
sont les départements et à leur tête les
preuves en tout cas depuis la révolution
française et à leur tête les préfets
faut-il les supprimer ou plus exactement
faut-il supprimer le corps préfectoral
on vit vous explique tout sur cette
réforme annoncée la semaine des as en
fin de semaine dernière par jean castex
et on en débat mais d'abord donc une
question les mesures de jean castex sur
la sécurité sont-elles suffisantes
c'est la question qu'on vous pose depuis
la mi journée sur le site du figaro pour
l'instant où vous êtes extrêmement
critique dans vos réponses
massivement critique à plus de 80% vous
répondez non mais je vous propose de
répondre du côté du muy d'écouter la
réponse du côté du oui du ministre de
l'intérieur depuis le début du
quinquennat nous avons pris des moyens
matériels et juridiques pour protéger de
policiers de gendarmes
sans doute faut-il continuer à faire ce
que nous avons fait plus début du
quinquennat et je crois que le produit
serait une raison
fière d'annoncer aux syndicats de
policiers les mesures la main ferme de
l'état ne tremblera pas et nous sommes
du côté des policiers des gens n'a alors
voici pour l'essentiel
les plus importantes mesures il y à la
fin du simple rappel à la loi qui va
être transformé notamment par des peines
de travaux d'intérêt général
la fin des remises de peine automatiques
pour les agressions de policiers
gendarmes
l'aggravation des sanctions pour les
agrégations de membres des forces de
l'ordre
une peine de sûreté de trente ans pour
les crimes contre les forces de l'ordre
le refus d'obtempérer sera réprimée plus
fortement et il y a un plan judiciaire
la création notamment la création d'un
observatoire de la réponse pénale avec
un référent dans les parcs et pour
justement observé quelle est la réponse
pénale à quai les réponses apportées par
la justice à ces agressions contre les
policiers
voici ce qu'en a pensé l'un des
responsables des syndicats reçus par
jean castex hier à la sortie de la
réunion c'est le responsable de l'unsa
police
le sentiment qu'on a c'est une prise de
conscience du gouvernement est
d'ailleurs une prise de conscience qui
est nécessaire puisque aujourd'hui
évidemment les policiers attendent une
réponse de nos gouvernements mais pas
que les citoyens aujourd'hui son inquiet
son inquiet de la montée de la violence
dans notre pays et sont inquiets et
évidemment quand on s'attaque aux forces
de sécurité intérieure
alexis est ce que on ne peut pas dire
quand même que la fermeté est de retour
devant cette batterie de mesures qui
sont avancés et quand on entend la
réaction de par exemple de cet élu
syndical on peut dire je pense sur de
bonne foi qu'elles vont dans le bon sens
ça paraît évident on peut dire aussi qu
elles sont prises sous la pression
sûrement un peu tard je vous rappelle
qu'on sort d'une grande loi sur la
sécurité globale on en a discuté pendant
des semaines et des semaines et des
semaines et tout à coup elle devait pas
être suffisant de cette loi sur la
sécurité globale puisque tout à coup on
invente de nouvelles mesures donc ça
prouve qu'on avait sans doute pas pris
conscience de la mesure du du problème
après est ce qu'elle sera suffisante
évidemment que ça sera pas suffisant
mais c'est un va déjà dans le bon sens
si on peut carrément salué quelques unes
le la fin du rappel à la loi
le rappel à loi c'est un truc avait été
inventé par jospin en 99 je crois qui au
fond une sorte de mener station
qui peut le cerf les policiers c'est
parce que la réalité dans les quartiers
c'est que le jeune après des séjours ou
pas des jours de la fin est arrêté et
conduit au commissariat
et il hérite en tout et pour tout d'une
d'un rappel à la loi à caen et qu'à un
quart d'heure après ils paieraient ils
plastronnent dans son quartier en disant
ah ah je les ai bien on commence donc le
rappel à loi
cette sanction qui n'en est pas une
parce qu'aujourd'hui les délinquances
alors fait plus peur de se faire gronder
par un par un juge
le fait qu'on la supprime ça me paraît
dans le bon sens mais c'est sûr de la
peine incompressible évidemment ça va
dans le bon sens
une mesure dans lequel on parle peu qui
me paraît très intéressante c'est
l'observatoire de la réponse pénale si
cet organisme va jusqu'au bout ça peut
être tout à fait intéressant et très
vertueux pour faire la vérité sur cette
éternelle question qui est celle de la
sévérité ou pas ou du laxisme de la
réponse pénale car il n'y a pas de
statistiques dans ce pays je pense qu'il
y en a pas parce que on ne veut pas
qu'il y en ait jusqu'à présent on ne
voulait pas qu'il y en ait mais si on
met en face les crimes et les délits
commis les peines encourues
les peines prononcées les peines
réaliser on aura là une vision globale
objective de la réalité de la sévérité
de la justice par rapport au fait je
pense que ce serait très utile et je
pense qu'à ce moment là on se rendra
compte que ce qu'on sait déjà qu'en gros
les gens font mieux la moitié de la
peine qui a été prononcée est
généralement un quart au moins du quart
de la peine encourue
donc ça pose comme une centaine de
questions vous de vis-à-vis de
l'application de la loi et du respect du
peuple souverain au nom de qui la régit
justice est rendue
mais je veux pas être plus long béatrice
certains syndicats comme allianz déjà
réclame plus ils réclament notamment un
changement dans la constitution pour
instaurer des peines minimales ou des
peines incompressibles
ils ont raison non et non parce que ça
changera rien parce que c'est nous c'est
pas la peur des trente ans qui va faire
que un jeune homme de 19 ans se trouve
armés dans son poing deal avignon et
et tire quand y tire il pense pas ou 30
ans qui vont être incompressibles donc
je ne crois pas que ça change quelque
chose si vous voulez dans le règlement
de cette violence chez des gens très
jeunes parce que ça ça me semble
effectivement une évolution préoccupante
non pas que l'ensemble si vous voulez de
la violence soit général et explose mais
assurément chez les plus jeunes
il y à un véritable une véritable
aggravation donc et à ce moment là on
raisonne pas en fonction de la peine
qu'on va avoir
donc je c'est pour ça que je dis on leur
mettrait 50 ans ça change pas et hélas
rien en revanche il y a un gros travail
à faire si on met en prison
pour en faire quoi qu'est ce qu'on fait
est ce que on a un travail
d'accompagnement de formation de de
façon à ce qu'on ressorte pas pire que
comptent-ils qu'on est rentré d'une
certaine façon
alors je les xives évoqué effectivement
cet observatoire
avec un référent dans chaque parc et je
trouve que c'est une excellente idée
c'est vrai parce que quand même les
juges on dès qu'on essaye de de porter
un jugement sur un juge
aussitôt ça hurle dans la corporation
c'est généralement quand ils font une
bavure d'une bêtise ils sont plutôt
déplacé pour mu qu'autre chose c'est
quand même dupond-moretti ka di sicilia
propos du féminicide quel lieu en
gironde à mérignac rien à ce moment là
bon bon mais sans être dans le risque
zéro non mais c'est ce qui vit à oui non
il n'a pas seulement dit ça il a dit on
va faire une inspection et on va voir
comment les choses se sont passées bon
ça me semble être des positions
importantes
voilà et que cette idée d'observatoire
c'est bien pour qu'on sache
effectivement dès qu'il ya des
différences selon les juridictions tout
le monde et pas juger à la même aune non
plus à mêmes actes avoir des
interprétations et des peines qui vont
être différentes donc cet observatoire
me semble une très très bonne chose
autre
décision aux mesures annoncées qui me
semble très bonne comme l'a dit
d'ailleurs très justement alexis c'est
bien évidemment arrêter avec ces
admonestations sur des jeunes qui n'ont
rien à faire qu'à attendre que ça passe
avec au contraire des travaux d'intérêt
général mais ça veut dire ça qu'il faut
des gens pour encadrer pour faire
correctement les choses autrement bon
c'est ça sera un coup d'épée dans l'eau
c'est le c'est vrai que dans ce que vous
dites
en tout cas les commentaires récurrents
par rapport à la question qui est posée
sur le site du figaro c'est le
commentaire que l'on peut lire de 7
internautes mais énormément qu'ils ont
dans le bon sens le vrai sujet c'est
l'application des peines prévues par la
loi
si les juges ne condamne pas ils peuvent
pas ils peuvent faire toutes les lois
qu'ils veulent ça ne sert à rien nicole
dit également en ce moment à quoi cela
sert-il puisque les mesures ne seront
pas appliquer les lois existent déjà
qu'on les applique
surtout au niveau des juges et antoine
encore il existe déjà des lois pour
protéger les fonctionnaires de police
encore faut-il donner les moyens à la
justice et à la police de l'est de les
appliquer il ya un autre internaute qui
dit il faudrait remettre la tolérance
zéro comme ça avait été le cas à new
york et à londres
avec tony blair oui je suis assez
d'accord avec tout cas la première
partie de l'analyse qui consiste à dire
que la clé c'est effectivement
l'application décision de justice c'est
vrai que renforcer les lois renversé loi
renforcer les lois c'est un des signaux
qu'on envoie ce n'est pas forcément
inutile mais il ya un moment la question
essentielle c'est de l'application des
lois
c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment souvent
que la loi est appliquée avec une très
grande mansuétude alors parfois par a
priori idéologiques qui est présent chez
grand nombre de juges
finalement l'idée que la répression
c'est pas bien que la prévention c'est
mieux que la prévenue de l'école que la
prison et l'école du crime mais je ne
suis pas absolument faux mais so what
que la culture de l'excusé que
finalement c'est pour des raisons
sociales que les délinquants sont ce
qu'ils sont donc il ya cette idée là et
ça chacun le droit de le penser ne
prennent que si le législateur c'est à
dire si les électeurs ont pris vie
ressemble de loi c'est pas aux juges à
les amandiers à les adoucir les tournées
autour parce qu'ils considèrent en leur
for intérieur ce qui est estimable mais
qui passe il vous en faut dire que non
elles sont trop ces versets l'indivision
des peines n'est pas l'individualisation
du jugement par rapport à la loi falaise
il ya quand même une espèce de
relativisation de la loi par un partage
d'un son nombre de juges qui je pense
critiquable et qu'on a le droit de
critiquer après il ya pas que ça il ya
aussi souvent que les juges s appliquent
les consignes qu'on leur donne et
notamment qu anthony qui met pas les
gens en prison c'est aussi tout bêtement
il n'y a pas de place en prison et donc
les juges on leur dit non à arrêter dans
les gens en prison et c'est vrai que et
sinon parce que si vous avez raison on
en mettra des huit par cellule ça va
être horrible et c'est vrai que c'est
horrible
donc on construit pas les prisons on
demande aux juges de paris les gens les
gens en prison et après on dit eh bien
ce qu'on va faire alors on va faire des
bracelets des peines de substitution des
potes de mai au lieu de partir de
l'utilité de la peine des peines de
substitution c'est une variable
d'ajustement parce qu'on n'a pas de
place en prison et les résultats c'est
que on sait très bien qu'en dessous de 2
ans de prison dont on fait zéro présent
c'est quand même pas normal
comment voulez vous autant je crois que
je rejoins grèce quand elle dit que
l'immensité de la peine ne retient pas
le type quand ils tirent encore que on
peut se dire qu'après tout ça peut le
faire réfléchir un peu
mais si depuis qu'il est tout petit
depuis son premier acte de délinquance
car on va avoir le cv de ces du tueur et
de son camarade
on va se rendre compte que celle à 10/15
fois qu'ils ont été arrêtés et ses 6
depuis le début ils sont habitués à ne
pas avoir de sanction c'est sans doute
ça le vrai problème une faute pas de
sanction de fautes pas exception 3 folle
passion quatre fautes une mini sanctions
cinq fautes une toute petite sanction il
ya un moment où de d'esclaves en
escaladant ont fini par tirer sur un
policier
donc il faut prendre le mal à la racine
la la criminalité c'est comme une
pyramide il y as tout en haut
les choses absolument atroce que sont
les assassinats ou les meurtres de
policiers
may en dessous les agressions payés en
dessous les outrages et puis en dessous
les refus d'obtempérer tout ça c'est un
on parle de continuum de sécurité y
aussi un continuum de la délinquance
alors justement si on suit ce que ce que
dit alexis si si une faute un peul une
sanction c'est ça la politique de la
tolérance zéro qui avait été appliqué à
new york y est en en bretagne oui il va
pas été appliquée de la même façon à new
york et à londres ans et des cultures
qui sont sensiblement différentes
mais le point commun avec une faute
appelé une faute à une faute appeler une
sanction
alors il faudrait moi je pense qu'une
faute a à peine d'une sanction
il ya aucun pour moi il n'y a aucun
problème là dessus si si elle est aussi
et il n'y a pas que la répression il y à
aussi l'accompagnement parce que la
faute avec une sanction alors si c'est
une sanction pour quelque chose qui
n'est pas trop grave d'intérêt général
avec accompagnement réel pour pour faire
avancer il suffit de regarder ce qui se
fait parfois dans un certain nombre de
pays scandinaves où on se préoccupe
évidemment beaucoup de fois qu'on a mis
la sanction pour éviter que ye récidive
et avec des politiques qui sont très
différentes des nôtres il ya des taux de
récidive qui sont beaucoup plus faibles
nous on est à des taux de récidive qui
sont quand même très très élevé donc il
faut qu'on s'interroge sur qu'est-ce
qu'il est plus efficace parce qu'une
fois qu'on les a mis en prison
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour que ça
recommence pas parce que si la sanction
c'est seulement la prison et puis se
passe plus rien on les laisse en prison
six mois un an deux ans et deux ans pour
que sa g on n'est pas du tout sûr qu'à
la sortie on est quelqu'un qui est
compris qui est mûrie qui est avec un
projet de vie du tout en prison n'est
absolument sûr un qui vont pas
s'améliorer deux qui vont recommencer le
lendemain
nommé jacques sempé sont deux ans les
deux ans qu'ils ont d ailleurs pour
construire des prisons mais sam sam
frappe pour avoir aussi une étude dessus
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on annonce la
construction d'une prison quelque part
tout le monde hurle dans la commune en
question on en veut surtout pas j'ai
l'exemple encore du souvenir d'une vie
brisée au mans en alsace où ça a été un
temps infini pour moi c'est pas tout à
deux pas de crédits pour tenir de prime
passera pas seulement ça d'abord parce
qu on en met quand même en france un
certain nombre de gens en prison n'est
pas d'un bac 6 mhz
c'est en ne revenant à part les
statistiques de 2,2 d'incarcération
prison de 6 et enfin ses doigts en
europe en étant le moins bon oui mais
prenons le cas de la suède qui est
nettement moins que nous avec un taux de
récidive des boucles épisode i la fois
sentent pas forcément le même type de
peau
ils ont aussi des étrangers des
maghrébins des afghans des toutes sortes
de gens dont on nous dit que c'est eux
qui remplissent les prisons bon voilà
donc on peut aussi regarder les choses
moi je suis absolument pas c'est arrivé
là sans qu'un d'ailleurs à l'arrivée
récente donc est ce que justement ça
fait drôle parce qu'il y en a qui sont
là quand même depuis les années 60 sont
les seuls payeurs les 510 afin de durcir
très très longtemps et c'est à dire
politiquement aujourd'hui je conteste
absolument pas toujours mais bon je dis
que la seule sanction si elle ne
s'accompagne pas effectivement d'un
travail pour une sorte de réinsertion ne
résoudra que pendant un moment la
situation mais oui sûrement qu'il faut
accompagner mais en attendant il faut
déjà prendre les sanctions et moi il ya
quelque chose qui me frappe dont on n'a
pas parlé c'est notamment l'aménagement
des peines
pourquoi concertons comme normal
légitime que quelqu'un condamné à 10 ans
enfin 5
il me semble que du pur m'aurait dit a
dit qu'ils voulaient systématiquement
refusées ces gens sauf que supprimer
l'alcool regarde les raids en mairie
mais non mais j'ai pris mais cette
réduction automatique des peines mais il
n'ya pas que borg à l'automate et aussi
2 av il ya il ya cinq critères qui
s'adjuge 5,8 en tout cas il nous a dit
ça mais aujourd'hui il va de soi que
quand on est con à 10 ans on en fait
sacrer de deux choses l'une soit la
peine de 10 ans et justifier il faut
faire 10 soit elle ne l'est pas il faut
condamner les gens à 5 mais c'est est-ce
de principe ou pendre édition sont dix
vingt ans ça vaut dix 10 à vos 5 2 0 0
ça désoriente évidemment les gens ça des
gens des victimes et les gens disent
mais on se moque de nous il est bon donc
là il ya quelque chose qu'il vaudrait
mieux limite même à la limite des peines
moins élevés mais vraiment appliquée que
c'est des peines très élevé qu'on
n'applique jamais à plus de la moitié
après tout dépend aussi des gens que
vous avez
il peut y arriver que des gens dans les
coups de folie jeu français un
commissaire de police
une histoire qui a qui a tué l'amant de
sa femme avec son arme
il a été condamné il a été un prisonnier
exemplaires il a retrouvé une
réinsertion tout fidèle est sorti à quoi
sert de laisser quelqu'un comme ça
pendant dix ans il a fait 8 ans au lieu
d'en faire 15 et voilà il s'est réinséré
dans la vie voilà ça arrive aussi donc
il faut pas avoir que l'exemple du petit
délinquant qui a recommencé qui sent
dans l'impunité
mais il ya aussi des situations bon donc
c'est peut-être une femme sur presque
elles mêmes des enfants
mais bien sûr présent c'était déjà
énorme et je les vois qu'il est dehors
le temps après
même si je n'ai pas peur mais est ce que
le laisser en prison simplement parce
que la famille qu'est ce qu'il y aurait
eu de plus j'en sais rien je n'ai pas de
porte pas de jugement de valeur
je pense ce cas là on pourrait en
prendre c'est certainement d'autres
voilà est-ce que c'est ça la solution de
laisser les gens en prison jusqu'à 10
ans et pas jusqu'à 8 août jusqu'à 7
j'avoue que mes que ce soit pas
automatique ça alors je suis
effectivement complètement d'accord et
là on revient encore la question de la
gestion de la taille des prisons de la
plate des places de prison car en fait
la majorité de ces adaptations de peine
sont faites pour vider les prisons parce
qu'il ya plus sèche et donc
régulièrement on en fait partir on en
fait pareil on a regardé mais pas pour
des raisons généreux et humaniste que
celle de béatrice c'est pour simplement
pour des gens qu'il ya plus de place
mais oui c'est pas ses méthodes de
gestion de 2,2 c'est que de narnia
public privé dans la construction de
prisons
vous avez des souvenirs ça c'était à
l'époque de nicolas sarkozy a eu cette
idée là et puis on s'est rendu compte
que c'était effectivement sur un coût de
gestion bon parce qu'il avait apporté
les capitaux mais après dans le coût de
gestion c'était absolument abominable et
donc du coup on a fait marche arrière
évidemment et que c'est que ça reste une
liste m'accordant veut engagée à
construire et à deux places de prison il
n'est absolument pas dans l'interview
qu'il nous donne indique sur les 10000
qu'un a construit en a deux
engagé je crois donc qu'il reste plus
qu'un an pour en faire huit bah oui et
quand la droite il n'a pas construit je
ne sais pas c'est reparti je sens du
travail et de la réponse pénale gens de
regarder s'il y aura plus de places de
prison qui seront qui seront construits
en tout cas moi m de gens présents pour
de bonnes raisons et non pas pour les
vider ouais alors pour l'instant vu
l'évolution de la délinquance c'est pas
moins qu'on va mettre c'est beaucoup
plus parce que justement les violences
policières elles ont explosé et les
violences anti personnel ont explosé
donc là pour le coup et tout le monde
est d'accord sur les chiffres il faut
garder mais il faut peut-être justement
qu'on sait qu'on n'est pas qu'une seule
réponse les mesures de castaic sur la
sécurité sont-elles suffisantes c'est la
question qu'on pose sur le site du
figaro et vous répondez non à plus de
87% en ce moment sur le site vous pouvez
continuer à voter je vous donne encore
la parole
avec cet internaute qui nous pose comme
question est le cumul des peines tutu
trois personnes et bien sûr c'est une
seule peine il faut autonomiser les
prisons nous dit propose axel maître du
travail des détenus mood modèles
pourront montrer s'ils veulent s'en
sortir et avoir des remises et sept
autres a noté un autre qui dit il ya
beaucoup de petits délinquants qui se
retrouve en prison et qui en sortent
encore pire avec des mauvaises
fréquentations et sans accompagnement
c'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
béatrice je vous propose d'aller sur un
autre sujet qui ne concerne pas les
prisons en tout cas directement sait
s'il faut supprimer les préfets rassurez
vous il est pas question de supprimer le
poste de préfet mais de supprimer le
corps dans lesquelles on les trouve le
corps préfectoral et tous les corps
seraient fondues en un seul et même
corps celui des administrateurs de
l'état
c'est ce que jean castex a évoqué jeudi
dernier devant donc le corps préfectoral
alors c'est un peu dans la lignée à la
fois de la conséquence de la réforme de
l'ena et de la volonté des modèles
macron de reformer je sais de réforme et
je cite le management de l'état voici
quelques unes des réactions sur twitter
marine le pen dénonce une déconstruction
préfectoral qui est un très mauvais coup
porté à l'intérêt supérieur du pays à la
neutralité de l'appareil d'état sur
twitter encore gilles platret ironise
alors qu'il faudrait renforcer un gilles
platret de vice président des
républicains candidats région bourgogne
franche comté alors qu'il faudrait
renforcer le pouvoir des préfets en lien
avec les élus messieurs macron et castex
supprime le corps préfectoral de l'art
de célébrer napoléon le 5 mai et
d'anéantir l'une de ses plus belles
institutions le 8 mai alors gérald
darmanin de son côté a répliqué sur
facebook et sur facebook et y lit que le
but est de conforter au contraire cette
fonction notamment en continuant
d'assurer la diversité et la qualité des
membres qui remplissent ses missions
béatrice est ce que vous partagez plus
tôt le point de vue de marine le pen
gilles platret ou celui de gérald
darmanin
j'avoue que je suis pas une fanatique
des grands corps voilà
parce que effectivement appartenir à un
corps quand vous sortiez dans la botte
inspecteurs de finances ou cour des
comptes ou autre bon ben voila c'était
tout tracé vous êtes très jeune mais est
au fond l'itinéraire va va se poursuivre
bon je pense qu'il ya quelque chose de
de symbolique suis pas sûr que ce sera
le bon moment parce qu'il est évident
que annoncé la suppression de cordée
préfet qui sera dans l'idée des gens la
suppression des préfets est ce que tout
le monde n'a pas une idée de ce que
c'est que le corps de la préfectorale va
évidemment faire faire hurler bien sûr
d'abord les presser et les anciens
préfets bien sûr on n'aime jamais que
son corps soit dissous bien sûr par
extinction du temps déjà et puis l'idée
que le préfet c'est l'état non pas que
l'état ne sera plus présent dans les
régions et dans les départements la
fonction restera certains disent oui
mais il n'aura plus la légitimité
il aura pu l'être légitimité puisque il
sera nommé au fond en fonction des
vertus que les gouvernements lui aura
trouvé bon ce que de 17 ans
cet internaute le corps préfectoral
dépend de l'état et non d'un
gouvernement en place le risque c'est
signé le matin et que le pouvoir puisse
nommer que je peux je pourrai dire à
votre internaute que c'est pas vrai
parce que vous savez très bien qui
compte la droite reprend pouvoir après
la gauche il ya la valse des préfets
parce qu'on sait qu'il ya des préfets de
gauche et des prophètes droite et qu'on
la gauche est arrivée au pouvoir elle a
mis quelques temps réalisé qu'il fallait
changer les préfets de droite pour y
mettre des prêts faits deux plus
favorable et qui appliqueraient mieux la
politique du gouvernement
donc dire que le préfet est au dessus de
tout bon ça je n'y crois pas par
ailleurs on a toujours eu des préfets
qui ont été nommés à discrétion du
président de la république et du premier
ministre bon en fonction des vertus
qu'il est
non je reprend l'argument de ils seront
nommés par le gouvernement et à partir à
discrétion du gouvernement et à partir
de ce moment là ils perdront légitimité
ses dires est il si tu es quelqu'un
comme jean charles marchiani cas était
un grand préfet du var il qui était un
proche de charles pasqua il n'était pas
passé par la préfectorale il n'était pas
du corps des préfets et il a été cher à
klein l'a nommé préfet bon pour résister
sans doute des gens à gauche de la même
manière
donc on a déjà si vous voulez cette
soi-disant absence de légitimité
alors ce qui pourrait être intéressant
mais il me semble c'est effectivement
cette idée d'un corps des
administrateurs de l'état comme vous
l'avez rappelé avec cinq ans j'ai dirno
terrain d'expériences de terrain parts
entre tous types de gens et pas
seulement celui du corps de la
préfectorale
donc c'est essentiellement des
sous-préfets quand ils sont jeunes on ne
vient pas préfet tout tout seul et qui
effectivement après en fonction de leurs
centres d'intérêt de leurs goûts de
leurs expériences professionnelles
pourraient rejoindre
effectivement ce qui serait la fonction
de préfet voilà je ne ce qui fait la
qualité d'apprécier la qualité de
l'homme c'est pas là que c'est pas le
corps dont on garde vous approuver
plutôt la réforme proposée par évoqué
par park aztèque passer pour un c pour
donald français alexis quand même
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on s'est
un peu trompé j'avoue je plaide coupable
en disant est ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre la suppression des préfère c'est
la suppression le corps préfectoral mais
mais ya quand même un certain nombre de
jetons qui voudrait carrément qu'on
supprime le poste de préfet sur twitter
richard nous dit oui c'est un système
dépassé qui participent à la lourdeur
administrative c'est pas un peu quand
même un combat corporatiste que auquel
vont se livrer des ventes a fait c'est
surtout un coup bas de sept mois d'une
immense démagogie puisqu'il faut se
remettre dans le contexte pourquoi est
ce que tout ça a été lancée c'est une
prétendue réponse à rouges et les jaunes
moi j'ai pas le souvenir que le gilet
jaune il y aurait brandi des des
panonceaux pour dire supprimer les n'a
supprimé les corses près ceci cela sur
des soutiens au plus près de nous nos
impôts que vous nous avez rajouté pour
nous pour nous empêcher de nous déplacer
mais bon donc je trouve qu'une très
grande démagogie à s'attaquer au fond
une des rares choses qui a sûrement de
défauts comme toute institution mais
kinder chose qui marche dans ce pays on
en france à l'énorme problème d'autorité
on en parlait que la sécurité on en
parle de sécurité publique on entre on
nous rebat les oreilles que la question
du régalien et on sent bien que dans ce
monde qui se délite pas la question de
la sécurité au sens large vont prendre
une importance décisive
on a aujourd hui une institution qui
dans tous les départements de france
navarre incarne cette présence de l'état
du régalien qui fonctionne et on veut la
fiche en ralliant ils seront là non ben
si ceux-là on veut déjà symboliquement
la fiche en l'air
non ancien attaquant et en disant au
fond tout le monde les préfets sont
interchangeables eux mais n'ont-ils pas
que les précédents champions il ne
suffit pas donc j'aimerais e s qui le
comment dire premier reproche c'est de
dire il faut rapprocher les gens du
terrain on peut faire plein de reproches
ou encore la fusion des finances la cour
de comptes mais qu'on peut pas faire à
la préfectorale
aujourd'hui si une fonction ministre
hâtive est proche du terrain c'est les
préfets qui ont commencé comme quand un
jeune énarque qui sort et directeur de
cabinet dans une préfecture puis sous
préfet puis secrétaire général d'une
plus grande facture pull puis préfet
d'une d'un petit département puis préfet
d'un grand département puis préfet d'une
région il peut entre temps être
conseillés dans un ministère chargé de
la sécurité
conseiller du premier
directeur de cabinet brise directeur du
quai donc du terrain c'est celle et
connaisseur du terrain s'il ya vraiment
des gens on peut le on peut
éventuellement le dire les collèges
l'inspecteur des finances encore qu'ils
vont faire des missions on peut dire
pour la cour des comptes met vraiment
les prévenus ils connaissent le terrain
donc je pense que je reproche t-on
vraiment pour les préfets ne tient pas
je pense que la qualité de la vision de
rêver ils sont pas neutres évidemment
personne n'est laissé normalien de
droite et de gauche
mais ils ont quand même au dessus de
leurs opinions
ce sens de l'état ses sens de la
neutralité de l'état ce sens de
l'efficacité de l'état qui font qu'ils
sont capables de dire à des élus et de
droite et de gauche
non ça tu le fais pas ça non ça non et
aujourd'hui les préfets sont très
souvent un garde-fou par rapport à des
embardées clientéliste limite aux
limites de la légalité au limite de
l'honnêteté d'un stand et d'élus locaux
ils sont aussi capables ils sont bien
sombres de profession de dire aux
représentants des agriculteurs ça
manifester oui mais ça non il représente
l'état ici ils ont le sens de l'état et
donc on dit on va les garder mais on va
plus recruté par ailleurs qu' on va
recruter à la place d'autres
fonctionnaires donc des frontières de
quoi du mystère la culture de sécurité
sociale de mystère de pourquoi seraient
ces autres fonctionnaires pourquoi
apprendre des gens qui ne connaissent
pas le métier serait meilleur exemple
ils connaissent ne va pas recruter que
des fonctionnaires on va recruter des
gens hors de la fonction publique et la
batterie vous avez raison il ya la tour
extérieur
après ma sélection la proportion si on
considère que l'avenir
la majorité des préfets de son eau sont
recrutés hors de la fonction publique
on va faire ce qui se fait par exemple
aux états unis dans d'autres fonctions
les préfets n'existe pas saisi puisque
précisément les gouverneurs sont élus
eux mais eux
à cela on n'aura quoi des militants
politiques des militants associatifs
voir des minorités parce qu'on dira il
faut les représenter en fonction de
critères ethniques etc etc
si c'est ça qu'on veut mettre à la place
de jean cure lui avec leurs qualités
leurs défauts personne n'est parfait il
représente l'état je pense que c'est une
immense régression et quand on se
retrouve avec des militants politiques
ou des militants associatifs qui parce
qu'ils sont copains du pouvoir parce
qu'ils sont copains du président du
conseil général parce qu'ils sont
copains du président conseil régional
auront été nommé comme préfet je peux
dire que la neutralité de l'état
la lutte contre la corruption la lutte
contre les débordements
2-2 certain nombre de professions la
lutte contre acer donc de pouvoir
économique parce que les préfets sont
importants aussi de ce point de vue là
eh bien ça ça sera une très grande
régression elle en aura plus que nos
yeux pour pleurer
tout ça pour renaître à monsieur macron
de donner l'impression qui fait des
réformes en est il ya mille autres
réformes plus importantes que celles là
j'ai vu que vos points de vue était
quand même assez opposées sur la
question qu'ils étaient très
intéressants faut rappeler que il
restera toujours une formation des
fonctionnaires
il restera toujours un institut de la
formation de l'ensemble de ses
fonctionnalités conflit des hauts
fonctionnaires
donc je vois pas pourquoi on a ce
j'allais dire ce ce scénario catastrophe
qu'a représenté alexis je vois pas
pourquoi les gens sont près des skis le
corps disparaîtrait qu'il n'aurait plus
le sens de l'état moi j'ai travaillé
étaient fonctionnaires j'ai toujours eu
le sens de l'ena je vous prie toujours
eu le sens de l'intérêt général
ils auront le sens de l'état et le sens
de l'intérêt général on sait que le
copain cru qu'on leur demande mais pour
me qui vous dit que ce sera
exclusivement ce genre de sang qui
seront recrutés alors qu'il y aura une
formation qui aura été donné dans le
cadre non là je parle de ceux qui sont à
l'extérieur bas prix mais pourquoi
voulez-vous systématiquement que les la
masse des gens qui sont élus que la
masse des gens qui s'investissent mais
voit comme par hasard des gens qui n'ont
pas de sens de l'état
je pense que dans le col qui ya fait
pour les élus mais les élus ils sont
élus et le reste mais c'est sa fille qui
le voudront de leur réflexion et leur
tir de l'anglais ces passionnés qui dit
le préfet il le tire une sa compétence
mais les lego aller chercher des gens
moins compétents que des gens mais on
aura des gens tout aussi grande maison
puisqu'ils n'auront pas fait le pré il a
fait toutes ses études tout en face au
parcours en plexi sa vie alexis qui
nommera qui n'ont brader préfet pas
l'élu local
ben ça sera le premier ministre est
présent dans le public c'est bien
influence de deux élus et des présidents
de la république qui seront débat dern
et qui suivront au moins dix noms
j'avoue que je comprends pas bien l'idée
de casser quelque chose qui fonctionne
pour le remplacer l'essence qui
fonctionnerait moins bien pourquoi est
ce que quelqu'un il me dit qu'ils le
feront la même école mais est-ce que
vous pensez que la même école peut
former des gens pour s'occuper de la
culture des eaux et forêts de l'hôpital
de la préfecture et de la diplomatie
c'est évident et prendra diplomate et le
maître préfet à mon avis on a des
déconvenues prendre un directeur
d'hôpital et le maître préfet mais
prendra préfet le même diplomate c'est
pas forcément la meilleure idée le
nombre de gens qui ont fait l'ena qui se
retrouvent soit directeur d'hôpital
c'est pour les acteurs de cabinet java
est ce que là ce qu'ils ont fait les la
vendée verte et démonstratif et non ils
ont fait toute leur carrière et
d'ailleurs mais il y avait quelque chose
à réformer pourquoi est-ce qu'on
supprime pas les hôpitaux et les ars
voilà une réforme qui sera applaudie par
les français on veut attaquer le coeur
du régalien alors que ce qui ne
fonctionne pas ce qui à l'évidence a
dysfonctionné ce qui fait qu'on est en
retard sur tout dans ce pays par rapport
à nos voisins sur la question des
vaccins et sur la question de jugement
et basses et les rsa on est tous pareils
ont quand même curieux je vous propose
bon ça on a compris qu'il ya un vrai
désaccord dans tous les cas ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on a eu que le
temps d'entendre vos deux points de vue
et qui était tout à fait intéressant et
éclairant sur 7 sur cette question qui
était peut-être parfois un peu obscur
pour les internautes mais on tenait à
d'avoir avec vous ce soir axel nous dit
j'aimerais un système local via
élections alors ça c'est un système qui
serait à l'américaine il faudrait plutôt
rétablir des prêts faits qui ne sont
plus aujourd'hui que des carriéristes
ledit godeau le corps préfectoral pas
une haute idée le corps préfectoral
dépend de l'état et donc non d'un
gouvernement en place de 10 et antoine
le risque pour que le pouvoir puisse
nommer qui il veut et yann au moment où
l'on commémore les 200 ans de napoléon
fondateur de notre administration
supprime le corps des préfets s'est pas
encore fait quelle ironie
[Rires]
à dire vrai il faudrait supprimer
beaucoup de ce fonctionnaire estime
nadine qui ne servent à rien et qui
pourrait être attaché des fonctions
utiles et urgente
babineau comment on ne vous aurait pas
cité comme pour léna le gouvernement ne
supprime pas mais modifie la forme de la
poudre de perlimpinpin sébastien en soit
il faut bien que l'état contrôle son
efficacité dans les départs
moment mais une réforme du système
préfecture a notamment du système de
formation et nomination serait de bon
augure et nicole qui nous dit entre les
préfets les sous-préfets les préfets de
région cela fait beaucoup entretenir ya
peu de temps que ça il ya à peu près un
peu plus de deux cents 200 hauts
fonctionnaires qui font partie du préfet
il ya du coran 50 sous préfète du corps
du corps préfectoral
donc il ya peut-être d'autres d'autres
réformes il ya même un ancien élève de
béatrice giblin qui nous suit qui dit
qu'elle lui a mis un très bien son dea
et bien pour l'instant il aura il aura
comme comme surnom et comme ce dos celui
de beaucoup data d'internautes qui est
anonyme
à très vite sur figaro live et merola
authentifiée il est authentifiée merci
aux canes 12h06 vie pardon d'avoir un
peu dépassée détend et on se retrouve
demain même heure même endroit avec
guillaume roquette a très vite chiant
live
[Musique]